the world is under attack by zombies and
only one of the sexiest men alive
who is beginning to show his age can
save us
world war z yes a zombie apocalypse
movie that takes place
around the globe is it exciting you
betcha
not all the time though here's one of my
biggest complaints about it act one
is fantastic it's very personal kind of
feels like war of the worlds where it's
about a family
and they're all like just together and
they have to survive the zombie
apocalypse but then once the actual plot
kicks in
where you know it's becoming about the
military and the mission where they have
to go around the world
it sounds like that would actually be
the most exciting part but really
that's when all the drama starts
becoming effective there really isn't
even drama at those points
it's just talking about tactical mission
stuff but the best parts of this are the
zombie thrills
they have a lot of zombie stuff going on
and the zombies are actually pretty cool
when i saw the trailer i was worried
because of the visual effects on that
they looked a little fake but in the
movie they actually must have improved
upon them because it looked pretty good
and the best parts
are when they have the zombie makeup
nothing beats zombie makeup and nothing
beats away how they run in this movie
either
and how is the sexy star bradley pitt
honestly i think he elevates the movies
oh sorry
and how is the sexy star brad pitt doing
the movie honestly i thought he elevated
the film a lot
i thought it might be a distraction
seeing brad pitt in a zombie movie but
you know what he really believes
everything that's going on he's a really
caring father
he's also a badass he also squints
here's most of his lines in the first
act
honey honey
i'm not even joking that's that's
literal i was literal
so i can see why a lot of critics are
actually talking about him because yes
he does do a really
solid job but you know he is getting
those wrinkles
yep starting to look wrinkly
wrinkle pit i was really thinking about
this before i did the review
would i suck brad pitt's dick i would
but now i'm worried he has a wrinkly
penis director mark
forcer he is the director of this movie
that's why i introduced him as director
mark forcer i was a little concerned he
did this movie called quantum of solace
it was about this guy named james bond
um that movie sucked then he followed up
with another movie called machine gun
preacher which i heard
wasn't the greatest of all movies ever
made
now he's back with world war z and you
know what he does a really good job
honestly this is an
entertaining blockbuster picture is it
scary no
it's more of a science fiction type of
thriller but it is really thrilling like
i said drama is not effective but it
tends to go
drama thrills drama thrills drama
thrills so there's enough thrills to
keep you entertained for two straight
hours what i will say that kind of sucks
is that
all the craziest shots are in the
trailer all the best scenes in the chat
everybody's like oh my god are you gonna
watch this [ __ ] movie
are all in the trailer then i mean
there's a few exclusions there's
actually some really good cinematography
in this movie i especially like the
finale of this film don't know why it
cost so much money to reshoot it but i
i guess they had to last good thing
about this movie
matthew fox yes
yep can i get a picture of him from the
movie
i don't think the director could either
some of you are probably saying matthew
fox isn't in the movie guess what
dumbasses he is he's in the scene where
i am
sucking matthew fox's dick i mean it
might be hard to notice him he gets a
little
lost in the picture you can't get a very
good vantage point
on him from the angles they chose it's
hard to see him in most scenes because
he's usually in
a party of five enjoying these buttons
another thing i really appreciate about
this movie it gets straight to the point
ha
another pun so yeah lack some compelling
drama but it's a zombie flick
and there are some good zombie thrills
backed up with a solid performance
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say world war z
got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my show why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below
and tell me what is your favorite brad
pitt
movie and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of world war z go ahead
and check out my show called reasons to
see that i do with my buddy jerry where
we're going to give you reasons to see
and not to see world war z and if you
want to go ahead and follow me on
twitter you can click the link right
here
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
is out
go ahead and subscribe to my channel by
clicking on the link right here
where the real war is at world war
d
penis
you